[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport à
l'émission est toujours consacrée à
l'actualité sportive dans le département
a c'est parti pour le sommaire hockey
sur gazon le racing club de france a
terminé la phase régulière de première
division par une victoire contre le
stade français et joueront les play off
de fin de saison contre saint germain le
résumé dans ce magazine
insolite un entraînement digne des
militaires ou des pompiers baptisé
bootcamp était organisée ce samedi à
saint jean les coups de projecteur sur
cette session intensive solidarité c'est
une tradition dans les yvelines la 27e
édition du tibre etc roland garros est
programmée le mardi 21 mai au golf de la
queue-lez-yvelines des sportifs de haut
niveau vont s'affronter sur les greens
pour la bonne cause plus d'informations
à suivre l'actualité sportive de la
semaine c'est maintenant sur tv 78
[Musique]
mais avant de développer ses titres du
rugby pour commencer ce 7,8 sport les
versets ils ont fait les joueurs de la
cité royale ont remporté ce week end au
bouclier deux titres de champion ile de
france
la réserve l'emportent 29 à 28 face aux
skiffs sur terrain neutre et l'équipe
première a réussi à battre vincennes sur
le score de 17 à 12
on écoute le responsable communication
du club pierre chevalier il nous parle
de cette saison historique
prochain objectif pour les versets y est
allé chercher un titre de champion de
france honneur dans les prochaines
semaines pour cela ils devront battre
lille ce dimanche au sur terrain neutre
un ou une autre information rugby la
rumeur enfle depuis plusieurs jours et
elles devraient être confirmés d'ici
début juin une partie du sky rugby de
montigny le bretonneux pourrait
fusionner à la rentrée prochaine
l'idée principale serait de regrouper en
une seule et même équipe seniors les
deux entités l'équipe qui aurait un
nouveau non serait amenée à évoluer en
promotion honneur division dans laquelle
évolue le sky rugby et féminines de
montigny le bretonneux conserverait
quant à elles leur nom et leur statut
cette décision sera étudié lors de
l'assemblée générale des deux clubs
à fin mai les chiens un mot de karting à
présent le jeune prodige dit milhas 10
ans était ce week-end sur le circuit
d'angerville dans l'essonne pour
participer à la wsk dans la catégorie 60
min sous un ciel couvert et un vent
frais les bleus en courtois terminé 2e
de la première course et a pris la 9e
place dans la finale à après avoir subi
un accrochage on écoute ses réactions
un problème moteur je suis parti une
fois on pariera 3 il fut remonté car on
m'a démangé fait les meilleurs tours en
course je suis content sa prochaine
course sera dans quinze jours en italie
on continue par du handball dans le
championnat de nationale 3 plaisir en
difficulté n'a pu faire mieux que match
nul à l'extérieur sur le terrain de
bois-colombes score final 23 23 au
classement ce résultat n'arrange pas les
plaisirs while points toujours une
inquiétant 10e place une place synonyme
pour l'instant de relégation pour le
club
on continue par du handball féminin dans
le championnat de nationale 2 rien ne va
plus pour montigny le bretonneux les
filles de denys choulet ont perdu ce
week-end sur le terrain de l'étoile
sportive colombienne sur le score de 32
à 25
une défaite qui fait redescendre
l'équipe à la huitième place du
classement lésigny montanes affiche un
bilan de 8 victoires pour 10 défaites
depuis le début de la saison
une fois n'est pas coutume nous allons
parler hockey sur gazon le racing club
de france 20 fois champion de france
veut jouer ce week-end à versailles
contre le stade français dans le
championnat élite ils l'ont emporté 5 à
2 le résumé du match des images de
marylène iapichino un montage de
exergian c'était le choc de cette
dernière journée élite le racing club de
france 4e recevait ce dimanche 28 avril
à versailles le stade français classé
troisième après une première période
équilibrée les locaux ont réussi à
prendre l'ascendant pour l'emporter sur
le score de 5 à 2 ça s'est plutôt bien
passé puisqu'on gagne 5,2 à deux donc
c'est plutôt un bon score on est content
du résultat
après sur la manière il ya quand même
des choses qui sont perfectibles
beaucoup d'erreurs techniques
je sais pas si c'est le terrain où notre
niveau d'implication mais beaucoup
d'erreurs techniques qui ont fait que
certaines occasions qu'ils étaient bien
mises en place n'ont pas pu aboutir
on avait à coeur de bien finir cette
saison contre une équipe sur lequel on
avait perdu
au match aller et du coup voilà on a un
petit peu rétabli les choses et c'était
important
avec cette victoire le racing club de
france terminent la phase régulière à la
quatrième place ils joueront en demi
finales de playoffs contre leurs voisins
de saint germain l'équipe qui a terminé
première de la division avec seulement
deux défaites au compteur
on est clairement outsiders mais on sait
jamais au match aller ici on avait fait
3 3 au retour on a perdu 5 3 mais il
s'était passé des bonnes choses je pense
qu'on peut on peut les embêter
en tout cas nous on y va pour gagner ça
c'est sûr et certain
on sait que sur un ou deux matches on
peut on peut les battre
le derby entre les deux équipes il vit
noise est programmée ce samedi 4 mai à
partir de 17 heures au camp des loges à
saint germain en laye après le hockey
sur gazon va parler de roller hockey la
ville d'elancourt abrite l'une des
meilleures équipes du département sont
les chocs ce d'elancourt pour nous
parler de ce que nous recevons sur ce
plateau le président nicolas thomas les
joueurs et joueuses nicolas nicaise et
tiffany soligo ainsi que vincent a
miossec responsable de section course
bonsoir on sort avant de parler plus
précisément du club
est-ce que vous pouvez nous présenter ce
sport sont différents du hockey sur
gazon qu'on a vu précédemment
ouais alors sans connaître précisément
le hockey sur gazon c'est c'est
forcément différent puisqu'on est on est
sur des rollers comme comme celui qui
est actuellement sur la table
donc c'est un sport qui est un petit
frère du hockey sur glace qui se
pratique en gymnase avec le même type
d'équipement un joueur de moins sur le
terrain quatre joueurs au lieu de cinq
et surtout l'interdiction de faire des
charges qui est l'inde est l'un des
points qui est souvent reproché hockey
sur glace va par des néophytes qui est
en fait l'aspect violent qu'on reproche
souvent aux questions de la décharge
c'est à dire c'est à dire ddd contact
franc où on se rentre clairement dedans
quand le roller hockey ça reste un sport
de contact en terme de contact on
compare souvent au handball ou au basket
c'est à dire des sports qui reste de
contact physique mais mes sens sans
contact véritablement violent nicolas
vous avez fait du hockey sur glace
oui pressé de questions sur glace quelle
est la différence justement avec le
hockey sur glace première ce qu'on
disait précédemment ce sens par rapport
au contact complètement on voit un peu
moins vite en roller hockey avec cette
vitesse un petit peu moins élevée du
coup on sentait un peu moins dedans et
personnellement donc c'est ma première
année de roller hockey
ce qui m'a le plus frappé c'est la
différence maintenant termes de
température quoi hockey sur glace en
mcad la glace qui me permet d'avoir un
petit peu plus frais que j'en attendais
un peu trop chaud peut-être c'est ça on
néanmoins l'année prochaine
j'arrête complètement le hockey sur
glace et je reste que en roller hockey
alors du coup la différence est vraiment
frappante quand on est sur les patins à
le patinage est pas totalement de même
on est un peu plus appuyé sur l'avant du
pied en roller hockey quand en patins à
glace et par rapport au freinage c'est
plutôt l'inversé qu'il faut venir
s'appuyer sur l'arrière du pied plutôt
que sur l'avant tiffany faux quelles
qualités pour être un bon joueur une
bonne chose bah déjà faut avoir comme un
certain physique c'est ça qui est
compliqué c'est justement avec les
différences de gabarit entre justement
les hommes et les femmes mais on lisse
et surtout quand même du physique une
certaine endurance
parce qu'un match c'est long et puis
faut être à fond tout le temps c'est
comme du fractionné en fait le d'accord
complètement
moi je je je ne joue pas au hockey mais
mes enfants font du hockey effectivement
quand je les vois jouer c'était c'est
très très très intenses et effectivement
et tiffany qu'est ce qui vous a donné
envie vous de vous lancer dans ce sport
qui est pas forcément le sport numéro un
chez les filles ben c'était un peu par
hasard que j'ai trouvé sport et puis ça
m'a tout de suite plu
le fait qu'il y ait du roller parce que
le roller mais si ça amusant et puis en
fait c'est la diversité du hockey parce
qu'il ya de roller il ya le maniement
avec la crosse il ya aussi le fait que
ce soit un sport d'équipé du coup faut
jouer avec les ses coéquipiers et puis
ça c'est très intéressant l'aspect aussi
stratégique du hockey et on parlait de
contact
quand ça se passe chez les filles un bas
c'est pareil c'est les mêmes règles et
justement bon moi je joue donc en parce
qu'en fait il ya pas vraiment de
catégorie strictement masculines et
c'est plutôt mixte après il existe aussi
des championnats faits qui sont purement
féminin qui ont été rajoutés beaucoup
plus tard met donc les filles qui
faisait du hockey avant elles ont
toujours joué en mixte avec alizé hommes
et on suit les mêmes règles exactement
les moments et que président vous voulez
développer roller hockey féminin le
roller hockey féminin
on a essayé il ya maintenant trois ans
de cela je crois de monter une équipe
féminine à elancourt
on a malheureusement dû abandonner du
fait du faible effectif
ça reste un sport qui est quand même
majoritairement masculin on a des
difficultés à attirer en effet des
joueuses dans dans les clubs d'une façon
générale et c'est vrai que là dessus on
souffre de de l'aspect
bas de l'image du hockey sur glace en
fait est de l'aspect sport masculin
maintenant
chez nous les filles sont vraiment
inclus dans nos équipes enfin tiffany on
est la preuve on a on a d'autres choses
seniors qui jouait également avec avec
les guerres source c'est à dire vraiment
dans les équipes mixtes et à tous les
niveaux à tous les niveaux du roller
hockey français
le sport est mixte et en fait la seule
catégorie par genre qu'on pourrait voir
c'est qu'il existe en équipe et en effet
des équipes purement féminine
mais à ce jour il n'y a pas de règlement
pour une équipe purement masculine ça se
fait par par papa par niveau quoi plus
on monte en niveau malheureusement mon
trou de filles mais aujourd'hui on
assiste vraiment sur cet aspect mixte on
a des joueuses y compris en jeunesse
beau certaines joueuses sont aujourd'hui
sélectionnés au niveau 2 des équipes
ile-de-france des sélections des ligues
de france donc on a peu de choses mais
celle qu'on a on y tient et on fait en
sorte que qui progresse bien alors le
club s'est créé il ya environ une
vingtaine d'années vous avez aujourd'hui
200 adhérents environ
est ce que c'est un chiffre stable c'est
un chiffre en hausse puisque l'année
dernière nous étions un tout petit peu
en dessous de 200 cette année au dernier
recensement on est même à 215 donc ccc
en hausse
c'est en hausse essentiellement dans les
catégories hockey adulte où on a recruté
quelques nouveaux joueurs
adultes dans la catégorie roller pur
roller loisirs sur lesquels on donne des
cours tous les samedis matin et s'est
très fortement aux cette année dans la
catégorie course puis ce qu'on a on a
lancé cette catégorie officiellement
l'année dernière est vraiment très
officiellement fait année de façon plus
cadré et justement la course vous avez
peut-être en parler avec plaisir donc la
course c'est effectivement le roller
course ou le roller de vitesse donc là
c'est pas du tout le hockey c'est un
sport plutôt individuelle mais qui peut
aussi se jouer mon équipe donc ça
s'apparente beaucoup à du cyclisme sur
piste pour faire un peu l'amalgamme donc
ce sont des courses sur un patinodrome
on appelle sur un ovale qui fait 200 m
ou sur circuit routier et les courses se
jouent soit sur du 100 mètres du sprint
pur jusqu'au marathon voir l'ultra
marathon qui peut aller jusqu'à plus de
100 kilomètres sur ces courses donc ça
fait partie du club et gazin fait partie
du club également tout à fait alors
dernière question comment fait pour vous
rejoindre
tout simplement pour nous rejoindre déjà
que je précise qu'il ya également une
section compétition avec une équipe qui
est notamment en nationale 4 oui tout à
fait alors haut niveau au niveau des
seniors on a on a trois équipes l'équipe
loisirs qui est clairement orienté
débutants ou
ou personnes voulant vraiment faire ça à
côté en pur loisir et on a deux équipes
plus compétition l'équipe régionale et
une équipe nationale iv dont l'objectif
est clairement de faire la compétition
est d'avoir le meilleur niveau au niveau
jeunesse on a toutes nos équipes sont
engagées en championnat ça c'est sur la
partie roller hockey sur la partie
course il ya un certain nombre de
courses en effet dans lesquels on est
engagé donc pour nous rejoindre le plus
ferme dans l'immédiat c'est déjà de
venir nous voir lors du forum des
associations elles encourent les seuls
cinq ans qui se tiendra le 25 mai le
samedi 25 mai et sur lequel nous serons
présents avec un certain nombre de parts
1 de prêt d'équipement de prêt pour que
les gens puissent essayer
on peut aussi évidemment nous contacter
par mail ou par téléphone mon téléphone
est sur le site et et venir faire des
essais lors de l'entraînement
il n'y a aucun souci là dessus pour voir
si logement repli merci avocat d'être
passé dans ce plateau on souhaite à
l'équipe senior d'aller le plus haut
possible dans les prochaines années et
on souhaite au club d'attirer de plus en
plus de licenciés
merci beaucoup on continue par du volley
ball chez les féminines dans le
championnat de nationale 3 vélizy s'est
imposé ce week-end trois sets à zéro sur
le teint de l'élan sportif de carpiquet
25 18 25 12 et 25 12
une victoire qui permet au véhicule de
rester à la troisième place du
championnat avec 37 points après 18
journées à disputer
toujours en volleyball ce mais cette
fois ci en nationale 3 masculine vélizy
reste à la cinquième place malgré sa
défaite à l'extérieur sur le terrain de
laval ce dimanche malgré une belle
opposition et se sont inclinées 3 sets à
1 le score 25-23 25-18 20-25 et 25-19 le
podium et a à 7 points
cap sur saint germain en laye en
entraînement digne des militaires ou des
pompiers est baptisé bootcamp était
organisée ce samedi matin dans la
commune une vingtaine de personnes a
souffert pour passer les obstacles manon
varaldo les a suivis à montage de xavier
gens dans la forêt de saint germain en
laye samedi matin les températures sont
plutôt fraîches et pourtant une
vingtaine de personnes est venue
participer aux buttes campe une création
de l'armée américaine mon corps ne peut
on rentrer le veau on peut par la place
il aurait le droit inspiré des
entraînements militaires les
participants enchaînent les exercices
intensifs de renforcement musculaire et
de cardio c'est sympa ça change de
l'ordinaire en faisant de la chance
parce que il peut pas donc
non c'est sympa ça fait travailler un
peu tout car jolis muscles du sport en
plein air c'est c'est génial ça fait du
bien au groupe sa part une bonne
ambiance c'est chouette
[Musique]
place à présent à l'activité de
brancardage puis parcours d'obstacles
qui s'inspire de celui des combattants
de l'armée de terre et tout ça sous les
ordres des encadrants confié de
formation
donc plus compliqué on va dire c'est de
s'adapter à chaque niveau de personnes
et de créer des parcours uniforme on ne
veut pas qu'ils aient des gens qui
soient laissés sur le côté on veut que
on est vraiment cet esprit de groupe et
de camaraderie entre les adhérents
le dépassement de soi l'une des
motivations principales des participants
à l'occasion de ce bout de campagne
forêt de saint-germain-en-laye tout son
groupe comme ça ça ça motive c'est ont
sans quoi on s'encourage les uns les
autres et puis faire ce en pleine nature
avec les oiseaux qui chantent le ciel
qui est pas trop mauvais c'est magique
près recommencer préparation pour une
échéance défi sportif ou petite leçon de
vie tous les participants se
souviendront de leur bout de caen on
prend maintenant la direction de poids
siens centre national de l'arbitrage
pourrait ouvrir d'ici la fin 2021 à
quelques pas du futur centre
d'entraînement du psg près de l'hôpital
initiative a été proposée par la
communauté urbaine grand paris seine et
oise et la municipalité
on écoute justement le maire de poissy
karl olive au micro de patrick jacques
de dixmude on parle pas seulement de ce
qui est le plus emblématique entre
guillemets le football de tous les
arbitres le handball le basket le judo
tous les arbitres de france vont pouvoir
élire domicile ici sur le territoire
dans un centre national de l'arbitrage
on viendra parler évidemment de leur
expertise ne rira également les efforts
mais on verra également les suivre du
point de vue médical
le site pourrait également servir de
préparation pour les volontaires des
jeux olympiques
on ouvre une page insolite à présent
vous avez peut-être entendu beaucoup
d'albums d'aboiements dans la forêt de
sainte apolline à plaisir ce week-end au
refuge spa organisé son 10e as canicross
une course entre un mètre avec son chien
ou l'un des pensionnaires
marylène iapichino a suivi la meute
aujourd'hui macao est sorti de son
enclos il a la chance de pouvoir courir
avec wonder woman
les gros loup comme ça les gens ont peur
généralement donc quoi je suis là chaque
année pour sortir
gros le duo participe à la 10e édition
du canicross du refuge spa de plaisir
une centaine de chiens
certains du refuge certains avec leurs
maîtres et de toutes tailles et au
départ dans la forêt de sainte apolline
et ça va pas le faire parce qu'elle aime
bien être toujours en premier donc c'est
toujours une chaîne vraiment passé avec
mon chat très grande complicité
pour cette course anniversaire des
étudiants de l'université versailles
saint quentin en yvelines ont participé
aux projets de cette association qui
leur tenait à coeur la ressource de
partenariat pour la collation pour les
médailles et aussi au niveau tout ce qui
est communication sur l'événement
ressort de bénévoles et c'est un
parcours de 5 km avec des gays mail de
ravitaillement bien nécessaire et une
ligne d'arrivée méritée pour les canidés
maîtres et chiens sont fiers de poser
sur un dogue walk imaginé pour
l'occasion on a des chiens craintif qui
ont couru et une fois qu'ils courent ils
oublient tout donc ils sont à fond dans
la course et avec leurs maîtres
donc ça leur fait oublier leur peur donc
voilà c'est pour tout ça que le sport
avec un chien peut apporter énormément
si l'aventuré si pas de vous a plu il
existe une fédération des sports et
loisirs canins avec plus de 100 clubs en
france dont un à coignières un mot de
golf à présent la ryder cup 2018 a été
nommé événement sportif de l'année la
semaine dernière à londres par le
prestigieux bureau britannique de
l'industrie du sport le tournoi qui a vu
les européens s'imposer face aux états
unis sont au score sur le golf national
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines accueilli
près de 270 mille fans venus du monde
entier fin septembre l'événement
également battu le record d'articles
parus dans la presse et près d'un
milliard de personnes en vue cette ryder
cup française à la télévision
la prochaine édition aura lieu en 2020
dans le wisconsin aux états unis on
passe maintenant à notre page agenda
[Musique]
on commence cet agenda par un événement
solidaire le tiebreak roland garros cet
événement sera programmée le mardi 21
mai prochain au golf de la
queue-lez-yvelines sur le green on
devrait retrouver des sportifs célèbres
pour nous parler de cet événement nous
recevons sur ce plateau la fondatrice
véronique chaplin ainsi qu'un
participant bombassei ex joueur de
l'équipe de trappes est aujourd'hui
joueurs de versailles bonsoir alors
véronique pouvez-vous vous présenter cet
événement alors le tibre est que c'est
une histoire d'amour du sport c'est une
tradition
c'est une tradition 27 ans et c'est
énorme de durer comme ça ça
rassemblement sportif de haut niveau de
toutes les disciplines et on essaye tous
les ans d'avoir de nouveaux sports même
insolites les adhémar par de petites
balles le tennis et le golf
et aujourd'hui on a des basketteurs on a
des athlètes on a des footballeurs des
rugby man avec un titre de champion des
champions qui est très convoité parce
que même s'ils viennent pour des raisons
solidaire pour les jeunes tous ces
champions je n'ai pas l'esprit de
compétition il ya un vrai esprit de
compétition il joue par équipe
ils s'entraînent dans l'ombre et je peux
vous dire que ce titre il est il est
bien convoité
alors quelles stars seront présentes
cette année alors on a des grands
champions de football
c'est à dire vous pouvez les dévoiler il
y aura deux trois joueurs du psg
d'accord il y aura des rugbymans il y
aura des champions de boxe il y aura des
basketteurs et il y aura également
beaucoup de femmes parce que cette année
on va vraiment axée sur la femme le
tibre est comme tous les grands
rassemblements attire beaucoup d hommes
sportifs et les femmes au moins cet
esprit de corps et cette année j'y
tenais parce que tous ces jeunes qu'on
soutient mais derrière il ya un papa et
une maman et donc on va avoir des
comédiennes et des sportifs de haut
niveau qui seront présentes notamment
sur les ateliers les olympiades alors
bombassei vous êtes le petit nouveau
cette année
pourquoi vous avez voulu rejoindre la
bande basse et avec un plaisir que c'est
un grand plaisir que j'ai rejoint
l'équipe de véro donc
donc voilà tant que je viens participer
et mettre le basket en avant donc voilà
qu'est ce que vous allez faire pendant
cette journée belge aurait deux voilà
j'arrête tout ce qui est parcours basket
et donc voilà et aider à l'organisation
et le golf
mais bien que gc ca sur la première
balle parce que tu vas quitter tu vas
faire l'initiation avec le golf naturel
l'a20 et tu vas voir que l'année
prochaine c'est sûr que tu vas pas la
compet de golf et du coup il faut un bon
niveau pour participer quand on est une
star ou tout ne peut participer comme
bamba par exemple qui alors pas trop
l'habitude de jouer au golf apparemment
davantage moi moi c'est très
sérieusement je trouve que le golf est
encore difficilement accessibles en
france et des efforts qui sont faits
énorme de la part de la des clubs de la
fédération et ce terme est encore
beaucoup de choses à faire pour rendre
le golf accessible à tous et à travers
le tiebreak on a voulu montrer que le
golf était accessible à tous en mettant
des jeunes sur les greens et on se rend
compte qu'au bout de deux trois heures
il était très doué avec des méthodes
d'éducation du geste naturel ont joué au
golf comme on marche et d'autre part
c'est également très éducatif sur le
plan humain donc cette compet de golf
elle est en équipe c'est à dire que les
gens ne jouent pas individuellement y
joue pour l'équipe avec une formule qui
s'appelle scramble cirque les quatre
joueurs dont professionnelle tap la
première balle et ensuite on joue la
meilleure balle des quatre avec de la
technique et la tactique parce que
parfois c'est pas la balle la plus
proche du trou qu'il est plus facile et
donc il ya un vrai esprit de kits équipe
qui fait que même un débutant mais
quelqu'un qui joue pas très bien mon
petit niveau de golf peut permettre à
l'équipe de gagner donc bon bah vous
pouvez permettre à l'équipe de gagner
eux j'espère
il y aurait également les ateliers on en
parlait précédemment ce sont pour les
jeunes des yvelines oui tout à fait
alors on a trois écoles des yvelines
trappe également des jeunes de l'école
de bamba et de versailles et c'est un
tel succès ces ateliers que les golfeurs
ont voulu avancer la compétition de golf
pour tous participé donc on aura six
ateliers avec six sports représentés
mais aussi de la prévention santé du
bien-être bien s'alimenter bien respirer
y aura vraiment un atelier là dessus
parce qu'on sait très bien que le sport
c'est un ensemble
voilà un esprit sain dans un corps sain
et il y aura les fameuses enchères c'est
un peu la tradition également chaque
année
oui qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait retrouver
aux enchères cette année alors les
anciens la fin de la journée on voit la
face à ces essais en clôture c'est le
bouquet final avant la fête ce sont des
enchères 100% caritatives et tout au
long de l'année
les champions moi même avec l'aide
d'amis on récolte des objets collectors
et justement on vous en avait pas sur ce
plateau risk où elle a présenté avec
plaisir tous ces objets font signer et
ce sont des choses de match
là par exemple la raquette de djokovic
signé après sa victoire du dernier grand
chelem ça c'est unique c'est énorme
c'est vraiment un collector on est quand
même sur un golf et je voudrais
souligner que j'ai tous les ans 25
professionnels de caution c'est le
métier qui viennent bénévolement et
l'année dernière le vainqueur est un
garçon formidable savel felipe lima qui
fait partie du circuit professionnel qui
nous a offert son club qui a le titre
qu'il a remporté l'an dernier avec
kombouaré
il sera présent felipe il nous a offert
son club mythique
la raquette de yannick noah quand il a
gagné la coupe davis pour nous remercier
parce que les fervents membres chez nous
ils adorent le golfe il l'a découvert
aussi sur des événements comme le
tiebreak il est complètement mordu
et puis il y aura également quelques
quelques tableaux des oeuvres d'art et
des maillots également pas que je crois
que vous avez un maillot à côté de vous
le cavalier dédicaces et également oui à
droite
voilà il est noir parce qu'en ce moment
le psg c'est compliqué véronique chaplin
ou où va l'argent finalement alors cette
année ça sera ma dernière question
oui c'est une bonne question parce que
habituellement sos gazelle on a des
beaucoup de demandes pour soutenir des
centres des projets notamment au sénégal
d scolarisation d'enfants ça c'est à
l'étranger mais également les jeunes
talents d'île de france et cette année
j'ai décidé de reverser 75 % de ce que
je vais récolter à trois associations de
sportifs de haut niveau qui gère des
jeunes parmi eux d'en bas hassan ndam et
à monsieur extraordinaire qui a créé une
école au népal donc je vois là le
partage pas ce qu'on fait tous la même
chose et ça me fait plaisir
merci à tous les deux d'être passé sur
ce plateau jour appelle le tiebreak est
programmée le 21 mai prochain au golf de
la queue-lez-yvelines bonne soirée sur
tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]